on
bonsoir et bienvenue sur diagonale
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs émission ce soir spécial dos
hermanas le super tournoi espagnol
également au programme annonce de
l'actualité avec l'anniversaire de
cornouaille entre autres chefs people et
la défense lot jean évidemment quelques
résultats prépare son asthme
l'impréparation du grand prix du sénat
avec ce soir jean-luc chabat nombre soir
jean-luc non soirée loi alors ce tournoi
de dos hermanas jean-luc qu'est ce que
c'est qu'est-ce qui se passe qui sont
les joueurs donc dos hermanas et un très
fort tournoi donc de grands maîtres qui
organise et en espagne et donc nous
avons nous avons d'excellents joueurs
nous avons le numéro un espagnol miguel
lescaze qui est d'ailleurs actuellement
en tête donc du tournoi avec six sur sur
800 que servir avec cinq sur huit
exactement ex-aequo avec siri n'est et
drief oui tout à fait alors déjà on va
rappeler la base c'est un tournoi dit
fermé c'est à dire qu'il ya des joueurs
invités et tous nos rencontres tout le
monde donc ça fait longtemps qu'on a pas
rappelé que c'était qu'un tournoi fermé
donc on va peut-être leur expliquer oui
donc un apport est fermé c'est un toit
ou tous les adversaires tous les coups
concurrents se rencontrent ce qui ce qui
donne donc une formule très justes donc
pour le classement du tour voilà donc
oui donc effectivement c'est le principe
des tombes fermé classement ils
escaladent relief et ce mirin en tête
trois fois grand maître oui trois fois
qu'on met pour l'instant donc pas trop
de surprises dans ce tournoi puisque
puisque les joueurs les plus en forme du
moment sont son sont en tête du tournoi
à signaler donc la petite la mauvaise
forme du joueur de yvan sokolov qui est
je crois aux landais actuellement oui
mais donc bosniaque d'origine bosniaque
qui est on vraiment très très petite
forme puisqu'il a trois et demi sur huit
mais en ce qui concerne donc le haut du
classement donc là donc là l'agréable
surprise pour les espagnols d'avoir leur
numéro un leader du tournoi c'est une
petite surprise mais il est il a noté
qu'il est ce cas c'est quand même un
grand maître assez expérimenté qui a
entraîné notamment vladimir kramnik
c'est donc un très très bon joueur il
pointe régulièrement au top 50 mondial
c'est la star espagnole ici il est en
tête d'un tournoi ça lui est déjà arrivé
celui déjà rêver et de toute façon son
ca de la préparation le travail qu'il a
fait avec vladimir kramnik paye ses
fruits effectivement alors dans ce
tournoi il ya également une hausse tard
il s'agit de jeunes teymour radjabov il
n'a que 14 ans déjà grand maître
extrêmement prometteur oui donc tes mots
radjabov qui a trois et demi sur 8 c'est
très remarquable donc dans une
compétition d'un tel niveau pour une
première participation et un âge et à 14
ans et quand même un d un des grands
espoirs de
des années prochaines effectivement
notamment qui en plus il vient de bakou
c'est la ville où est né garry kasparov
donc effectivement le nouveau garry
kasparov et peut-être ici il s'agit
peut-être de radjabov en tout cas il à
la concurrence sérieuse chez les jeunes
avec notre etienne nationale le petit
freyssinet bon ponomariov et de ses
draps première ronde il commence en
battant krasnenkov donc il fait très
forte impression ensuite il lève un peu
le pied donc il est pour l'instant à -1
3 me sur vite c'est un bon résultat
le gros drame dans ce tournoi c'est
grâce à une offre un grand maître
polonais très très fort pas très connu
mais il a récemment été dans le top 10
mais top 10 mondial quand même ce qui
est pas mal
et là il a un point sur huit ces
extrêmes oui donc krasnenkov qui n'est
pas en forme semble-t-il
krasnov qui avait explosé je me rappelle
en 98 je crois à groningen aux
championnats du monde où il avait passé
pas mal de tours et
et à partir donc de cette période il y
là car il arrivait donc au top au top
niveau donc à la 2600 à peu près au
classement
il a eu deux mille sept cent une fois
rachat d'acs racines kof
mais ce n'est plus le cas donc voilà
après environ dont qui laisse khazraj
fesman en tête
on l'a déjà dit donc il est plus qu une
seule ronde a joué ses trois joueurs
peuvent l'emporter à noter que tout le
monde se tient dans un point et demi
mise à part grâce à un coffre qui est
aux fraises
voilà donc pour ce tournoi de ce super
tournoi de dos hermanas en espagne donc
résultats demain samedi on vous en dira
plus bientôt on va tout de suite passé
jean luc à notre première rubrique pour
ainsi dire il s'agit de la partie
commenté voilà donc pour ce tournoi donc
j'ai sélectionné la partie qui s'est
jouée entre drief et ses autres sokolow
et drief donc sokolov a les blancs c'est
une partie qui on va pas trop insister
sur sur la stratégie dans le milieu de
jeu dans cette partie puisque c'est une
partie spectacle c'est une partie où les
sacrifices fusent et je crois que les
les téléspectateurs vont apprécier donc
toutes les combinaisons qui ont qui ont
eu lieu dans cette partie c'est un c'est
un feu d'artifice sokolov donc avec les
blancs ouvre par le coût des quatre
drief lui tout son répertoire depuis
déjà pas mal de temps des 5
il est spécialiste de la sni slave le
jeu sur case blanche c'est ce qu'on va
voir c'est une garde donc drive qui est
un joueur extrêmement solide et qui qui
donc décide de jouer la semi slave son
répertoire habituel cavaliers f3
cavaliers f6 qu'avait laissé trois donc
la semaine dernière je crois qu'on a vu
une partie où s'était pas tout à fait
comme ça puisque les blancs avaient très
tôt décidé d'enfermer leurs
fonctionnements changement de 3 c'est
c'est une façon de jouer aussi pour bien
protéger l'option c4 est ici donc c'est
plus optimistes ce qui se passe puisque
après ces trois on voit que l'option ckt
emprise les noirs peuvent le prendre
choisi de ne pas le prendre en jouant
aussi c'est la 6 cela m'est donc sokolov
qui préfère rejouer ses pièces
activement donc là il sort le fou c'est
en lui de jouer le coup et trois qui
transpose dans les grandes classiques de
la deûle à mayran
il joue fou g5 et il est prêt à jouer
des positions beaucoup plus agressive
comme le gourbi baude vinik donc un
vieux gambie qui est que l'emploi à
obtenir dans cette position après
dépensé 4 immédiatement voilà alors
curieusement ce qu'il faut voir dans
cette question c'est qu'un gambie c'est
un sacrifice de pions ici après des
français captent on a l'impression que
c'est les blancs qui font que bambi
exactement exactement donc puisque dans
cette position les blancs jouent eux 2e
cat
les blancs occupent le centre avec leurs
deux pions centraux et ils menacent tout
simplement de récupérer le pion 6 4 avec
le fou f1 donc les noirs décide de
défendre de défendre ce pion en c4 en
jambes et sa conjointe b5 et pour
obtenir quelque chose les blancs jouent
eux cinq dans cette position ils jouent
aux cinq donc le cavalier est cloué il
ne peut pas bouger plus que la d'amendé
vite serait serai mangée par le fou dont
les noirs doivent jouer dans cette
position h 7h 6h 6 donc c'est une contre
attaque
le four revient sur h4 g7 g5 toujours
pour attaquer le fou est là dans cette
position après cavaliers proches et cinq
pions pranger 5 suivi de fou projet 5
les blancs en sac et fines pièces mais
vont récupérer le cavalier sur m6
puisque le cavalier ne peut toujours pas
bouger et après si on calcule on
constate que les que les noirs on a plus
ou moins voilà tout à la baisse en fait
vous voyez cette position ici c'est les
blancs qui vont avoir besoin de plus
alors qu'au début de la variante après
des procès car tu sais les noirs qui est
20 points de plus donc c'est le gambit
mode unique mais ne pas se tromper c'est
les noirs qui sacrifient un pion et
c'est une noire qui joue pour initiative
et non pas le contraire exactement
exactement donc après fou g5 il ya un
moyen qui a été mis à la mode
récemment jean luc enfin c'est pas au
début des années 90 donc oui la variante
de moscou donc h 7 h 6 et donc au début
des années 90 c'est encore un joueur
très connu c'est vladimir famille qui a
mis cette vente à l'ordre du jour l'idée
donc l'idée
et d'intercaler donc secoué h 7 h 6 le
fou si il vient sur h4 c'est la partie
donc là on ne commentera peut-être c'est
la partie donc si bons fous prend m6
c'est le coût normal mais après faut
prendre 6 les noirs obtiennent la paire
de fou oui donc les obtiennent la paire
de fou et se disent je suis mal
développés mais ce n'est pas si grave
puisque la position si elle s'ouvre ma
paire de fou va jouer si elle ne s'ouvre
pas eh bien je vais essayer d'ouvrir et
j'aurai la paire de foot oublier toutes
façons tout simplement pour résumer on a
un désavantage de développement c'était
les blancs ont sorti plus de pièces
maintenant s'il est blanc veut laisser
de d'utiliser cette avance de
développement faut qu'ils ouvrent le jeu
à ce moment là la paire de fou devient
compensatrice voilà donc après échouage
4 dépensé gâte
alors là c'est plus pareil justement
c'est ce qu'on va voir et là c'est
complètement différent de ce qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure puisque après eux quatre
les noirs peuvent s'intercaler
contrairement à la position de tout à
l'heure peuvent s'intercaler le coup g7
g5
oui puisque dans la position tout à
l'heure si il avait essayé d'intercaler
le coup h60 il faut pointe il y aurait
eu faux problème si suivi de france et 4
donc la g5 les noirs peuvent interpeller
donc jessains fou j'ai trois là voilà il
n'est plus question de sacrifier la
pièce angers 5 puisque maintenant c'est
vraiment sacrifice de pièces comme le
cuir est encore en vie 4
donc qui est proche et 5 n'est pas une
option il faut je me projette dans fou
g3 et la maintenance bessac b5 et là
effectivement les noirs on a besoin de
plus et vont le garder
voilà les noirs entendent plus en plus
ces évents gardez donc c'est une
position qui est extrêmement débattue
actuellement donc sur la scène et
chicken beaucoup de joueurs jouent ce
type de position et
et donc dans cette partie les blancs les
blancs donc on continuer leur
développement de manière classique par
fout d'eux alors il ya beaucoup de
solutions dans cette position il ya fohi
2 qui en est une île adams et 2 qui est
le coup un peu plus solide et il ya
également le cou aux 4 5 qui existent
donc il ya énormément de variantes mais
toutes ses variantes finalement ne
servent pas à grand chose si on ne
comprend pas le véritable débat d'idées
qu'il ya maintenant donc ce qui se passe
en fait c'est que les blancs ont depuis
un an au centre
voilà très fort et ses pions sont
souples c'est à dire qu'on peut soit
avancé furieux qui amènera une structure
plutôt fermés soit avancé le pion des
dents énormément car on joue le coût des
quatre des cinq qui fait complètement
explosé le sens donc ça c'est les deux
idées des blancs en attendant ils ont
envie de mettre le roi à l'abri
maintenant donc il nous faut deux et là
il ya des complications qui peuvent
commencer
notamment après je crois jean-luc dans
cette position non c'est pas dans cette
pétition donc foulé cette foulée 7 donc
foods je crois que je fous de ces la
grande ligne de toute façon il faut
abaisser le coût principal ou deux c'est
la grande ligne ou 17h cat donc h4 c'est
une réaction alors h4 c'est un peu
nouveau jean-luc précédemment ont
préféré jouer soit petit rock souad mc2
il y avait deux options h4 c'est la
variante à la mode agressive justement
mise à jour par yvan sokolov qui est
quand même un spécialiste de cette
variante ils vont sokolov qui est un
spécialiste mais bon dans cette partie
ça s'est mal passé hk tilly des
éventuels mais évidemment c'est aussi de
trouver la position noir donc puisque
les blancs qui ont un pion - on peuvent
ouvrir comme tu l'a expliqué au centre
par 5 mai après des coups comme h4 donc
il provoque donc les noirs leur
structure de pions étant menacé les
noirs ne peuvent bien évidemment pas
prendre le pion h4 ce serait ce serait
un suicide total et ici il joue g5 g4
lecavalier f3 se dirigerait alors sur la
case eu cinq attaques créent le plus
orange et 4 mais qu'il faudrait défendre
et affaiblir un peu plus puisque dans
cette position on ne sait pas où les
noirs vont remplacer leurs droits c'est
le problème des noirs oui tout à fait
ils ont beaucoup d'affaiblissement c'est
clair bon y'a g4 effectivement gcard
c'est quand même un coût possible après
qui évolue au sein qu'on peut jouer h5
s'amène des positions complexes mais ici
donc finalement briefe choisit donc
autre chose relief choisit donc
le choix le plus le plus concret puisque
il décide de prendre un deuxième pion en
jouant b5 bekkat voilà alors la d4 donc
c'est effectivement contre attaque sur
le cavalier donc driaaf qui oublie
complètement sa structure de pions
puisque là il s'intéresse plus il ne
cherche pas à donner donc une cohésion à
sas en place son jeu de pions
puisqu'après avoir lancé ce plan le fion
c4 se retrouve en reprise mais bon c'est
la position devient purement tactique
les pièces le jeu de pièces noires enfin
la question que se veut le débat donc
les noirs veulent prouver que leur jeu
de pièces est suffisant pour obtenir
l'initiative a noté jean luc dans cette
position que le coup h projet 5 n'est
pas vraiment viable c'est là on aurait
pu se dire ils m'attaquent mon cavalier
moi je vais attaquer le sien puisqu'il
ya tout simplement que si on prend
cavaliers et après si on prend cavaliers
tu comprends pions avec dont quatre sont
très ennuyeux en b2
voilà simplement donc après l'es4 les
blancs n'ont pas d'autre choix peut être
bouger le cavalier oui cavalli acat la
position devient extrêmement sauvage la
position devient extrêmement sauvages et
les couches vont s'enchaîner donc de
manière assez tactique donc cavalier
prend le cas tu attaques le fou en g3
fonds g3 qui est une pièce très très
importante pour les blancs donc il faut
garder ce fou fou ou 5 fois 5
alors on va on va on va pas trop ce qui
d entre guillemets dans cette position
puisque c'est très compliqué on aimerait
bien comprendre exactement ce qui est en
train de se passer
donc qu'elle prend 1,4 ça y est les
noirs ont de plus en plus maintenant cap
sur les compensations des blancs les
compensations de blanc sont extrêmement
tactique dans cette position puisque les
blancs ont bien développer leur pièce le
clan c4 est faible le
la tourache menace de jouer sur la
colonne h qui peut s'ouvrir puisque le
pion h4 attaque le plan g5
voilà des compensations principal donc
les coûts qui suivent explique un petit
peu toutes ces manoeuvres
est ce qu'on peut dire que oui alors
dans cette position est ce que est ce
que les coûts des noirs sont forcés dans
cette position les coûts des noirs sont
plus ou moins forcé je pense puisque
puisque les autres coûts seraient fcf ci
serait un affaiblissement ce ne sera pas
nécessaire un peu quand même envisager
lsf 7,6 à l'air d'être un coup on peut
l'envisager mais c'est un
affaiblissement de luxe et un
faiblissement mais on gagne un temps on
attaquant le faux 5 des blancs bon
effectivement ça affaiblit les cases
blanches le problème d'accès tf6
peut-être ce serait fou combes et 8 et
dames ses deux attaquants cavaliers en
leucate et le pion à ses 4 le pion ici
serait faible immédiatement donc dans
cette position en fait en jour et tout à
fait fou prend cavaliers b8 qui gagne du
temps en fait pour les blancs clients
astana outre inutile et les cases
blanches les cases blanches puisqu'on
voit qu'après f6 la diagonale h58 est
très très affaiblie et la diagonale
aussi b1 h7 est également très affaibli
puisque la dame sur ces deux pourraient
venir peut-être angers 6 tout ça c'est
une question de classe blanche voilà
c'est tout tout va se passer sur casse
blanche d'autant plus que le foucades de
cases blanches des noirs il est
complètement à l'ouest
exactement le pion doit rester sur f ça
qu'il faut jouer tout j'évite donc dans
cette position après phocéen kiev si ce
serait un coup très affaibli sont pas
positionnés du tout donc de relief en
toute connaissance de cause parce que là
on n'a aucun doute les joueurs sont
encore dans leur préparation connaissent
très bien cette position ils jouent tour
élite dames ces deux donc d'abaisser de
le développement logique attaque le
cavalier sur quatre menaces de récupérer
le pion c4 et préparent le grand roque
donc près par le développement du roi
quand le grand rodez avec ça fait déjà
pas mal pour un seul coup il y avait pas
mieux tout simplement
c'est un peu comme voilà donc ces cinq
c5 donc là drief montre il montre ses
intentions ses intentions sont simples
dans cette position c'est cette tenir ce
cavalier au centre henri iv puisque le
fou 17 contrôle maintenant il veut
éliminer
il ouvrait un petit peu la position au
centre et parce que c'est ça qui l'a
donc fait une défense forte du cac valeo
4 avec le fonds des sets mais mieux que
ça le fourbe et 7 maintenant est
vraiment dans la partie oui le foot les
sept qui gisait qui va jouer avec la
tonte g8 puisqu'on voit qui est ça c'est
un duo de pièces assez fort angers c'est
un vieux de pièces assez fort qui qui
empêche puisque les blancs n'ont pas
encore ok donc les blancs en le chantre
petite fille grand roque c'est un coût
qui interdit peut-être définitivement le
grand roque et ça devient dur petit rock
ça ça devient très dur psychologiquement
de faire le petit rock dans cette
position sachant qu'il a déjà une tour
le fouet le cavalier qui est assez
proche et le grand roque aussi est assez
assez assez risqué puisque les pions
noirs sont en face du roi on peut dire
dans un sens que pour l'instant cette
partie est pas vraiment éducative
puisque les joueurs fossé de la haute
stratégie difficilement compréhensible
oui c'est vrai que c'est une partie
extrêmement c'est une partie de deux
spécialistes
mais ce qui suit est vraiment incroyable
donc il va se passer des événements tout
à fait exceptionnelle exceptionnel donc
food rend ces quatre fous profession c4
après ses cinq ça c'est logique
donc maintenant il ya plus qu'un point
de moins il n'y a plus qu'un pur - blanc
récupérer un pion et ça continue ça
continue donc les blancs
on récupère un pion mais le pion des
cats étant prises par l'attaqué par le
plan c 5
alors bon évidemment les noirs ne
peuvent pas prendre directement le pion
c5 le plan des 4 puisqu'il puisqu'il est
défendu deux fois
voilà et par le khalife dang est fausse
il faut enlever un défenseur g4g 4g
quatre attaques lecavalier f3 oui et
enlève donc un défenseur une fois que ce
cavalier aura bougé puisque il ne va
bouger
en toute logique et bienvenu sur des 400
entreprises voilà donc sokolov lui n'a
pas on n'a pas dit son dernier mot
fourbe et cinq échecs une rôtie nuageux
pour l'initiative c'est un jeu de pièces
donc un coup intermédiaire alors ce
qu'il faut voir aussi jean-luc dans
cette position c'est que ici il ya un
proverbe qui dit mazette vos échecs
mazades fait échec en général on faire
un échec si ça a pas d'idée c'est pas
bon mais là l'idée est assez simple
c'est que le fou c4 est pas très bien
placé puisque il tape dans un duo de
pions qui se tiennent mutuellement très
solide donc cet échec en fait gagner du
temps dans la mesure où on fait chaque
et en même temps on replace notre fou
exactement et la dame ces deux attaques
les immédiatement le pion c5
voilà donc en fait il fait pas échec
pour faire échec mais il fait échec
parce que c'est un coût et il faut v5 à
chaque cavalier 17 le seul coup je suis
recettes ne serait pas très utile et
mettre une puissance et 6 perdre et une
pièce aussi puisque le cavalier a eu
quatre donc s'ils ont joué ces six ou
calle c6 calisesi ce pari gagné 6,7
immédiat dame prend aux cats et surtout
ses six on échangerait d'abord en c6
tout à fait donc floue mais sa cavale et
17 et 17 interceptions de l'échec
voilà et là dans cette position surprise
première grosse surprise de la partie
sokolov donc ne bouge pas son cavalier
il aurait pu ramener son cavalier en d2
oui c'est le coup le coût attendu dans
cette position qui existent donc c'est
le coût attendu
il ne l'a probablement pas fait parce
qu'après cavaliers d2
il est noir vont peut être échangé les
cavaliers sur des deux oreilles et
prendre le pion en g2 avec le foot
bessette prend danger de oui oui il ya
plusieurs options celle là et pas mal
pendant g2 ou peut-être joué à 6 aussi
des deux coups sont possibles annonces
et peut-être dangereux puisqu'il y
aurait peut-être une fourchette non non
mais faut changer de l'air tout à fait
bien fait moi j'ai un on peut mettre
notre fou sur une casse table qu'est la
case f3 qui empêchera le roi de landreau
quais etc
en plus on contrôle la colonne des
toiles a donc fou projet d un coût très
simple beaucoup de complications quand
même ici sur calais 17 c'est la surprise
donc à et des deux n'a pas été retenu
par yvan sokolov
il s'est dit peut-être je vais jouer un
peu original ou alors il s'est dit et je
veux le meilleur coup exactement et sur
cavaliers donc il joue original mais il
joue le coup qui semble très logique
c'est à dire dépenser 5
alors l'idée de dépenser 5 c'est que si
on prend en effet trois lui il va jouer
c6 c5 c6 et avec une fourchette donc il
perd une pièce mais il va en récupérer
lui voilà donc on peut envisager
évidemment puisque c'est très très
intéressant très complexe donc la région
prend cavaliers suivrait donc le coup
ces six fourchette menaces pions prendre
cet échec
suivi de près ce que maintes c'est à
dire qu'on est vraiment tout proche du
mat
donc là beaucoup d'options par exemple
si on prend les deux et là on peut
prendre on 17 d'abord où on peut prendre
17 on peut jouer tour g1 de joutes en
juin on est tout simplement s'il ne se
passe rien et maintenant il semblerait
que les noirs ces objets de souffrances
et 6 parce qu'il ya beaucoup de menaces
qu'on a cependant souvent 17 soit en
baisse est soi-même jean-luc henri iv
donc triple menace
ça devient vraiment trop d'autant plus
que le roi noir n'est plus du tout en
sécurité
voilà donc on va revenir à la position
donc après des prêts ces cinq là dans
cette position de les noirs ont joué un
coup exceptionnel encore une pointe
tactique fantastique
ils ont joué donc des 4 b 3 donc un coût
qui semble curieux qui semblent ils
semblent anodins donc on
pas trop ce qui se passe ce qui se passe
sur un coup sûr un coup réflexe comme
apprend b5 à prend b3 prend b3 oui j'ai
un lapsus révélateur à prend b3 donc il
y aurait le ku'damm à cinq échecs
oui qui gagnerait une pièce puisque la
dame a eu cinq attaques donc mais le roi
des chats qui attaquent le fond des cinq
se font v5 qui est très important
puisque c'est le coût qui permet aux
blancs de jouer c5 c6 voilà donc il faut
absolument pas le perdre donc dans cette
position de lecavalier
lecavalier a quatre qui peut défendre le
fou en revenant sur avec la c3 oui là ne
peut pas venir sur ces trois puisque la
dame à 5 va prendre la tour en 1 et
peut-être main après celle en h1 et
peut-être même la tour on h1 donc ça
c'est trop cher c'est cher donc sur b3
pas de coup réflexe en face que detroit
en fait ça fait de menace c'est comme ça
qu'il faudrait tenter de l'expliquer ces
attaques la dame et en même temps sa
menace damas cinq échecs puisqu'on a
libéré cette diagonale que je pointe en
rouge damas cinq échecs qui permet donc
de gagner le fou b5 donc double menace
voilà donc dans cette position sokolov a
joué le coup le plus logique il défend
s'en fout b5 avec la dame en d3 voyez
puisque la dame en d3 défend la foulée 5
et attaque le cavalier en 17 et en même
temps garder un oeil sur le carillon 24
exactement donc c'est une belle case
c'est une belle case pour la dame mais
maintenant on voit quand même que ce
colloque par ce petit coupé trois
rajoute quelques possibilités tactiques
à la position puisque il a ouvert la
grande diagonale à 5 e 1 et il a un pion
en b3 un pion aux baies 3 bon c'est un
pion qui avançaient assez loin c'est
vrai que là dans cette position on se
demande ce que ce pion va devenir donc
d'amd 3g prend à f3 oui donc les noirs
décide finalement de prendre de prendre
ce pion f3c 6 c'est ce qu'on avait prévu
tout à l'heure mais là c'est différent
puisque le pion et en d3 au lieu de b4
donc là c'est l'ouverture de la grande
diagonale qui va faire la différence qui
va faire la différence puisque c'est le
jeu de pièces qui compte est floue
bekkat échec alors une fois de plus
c'est encore un échec pourquoi fait-on
cet échec ont fait cet échec donc pour
développer la dernière pièce
et donc tout simplement pour développer
la place puisque dans cette position
tout est extrêmement tactique et le jeu
de pièces et la chose prédominante en
peut plus la structure de pions étant
complètement explosé là il faut il faut
donc il faut développer les pièces le
plus vite possible mais moi je pensais
je pensais aussi jean-luc eux ils se
préparent à encaisser pions prendre
cavaliers des sept échecs en ayant la
casa fuite pour le roi c'est peut-être
un moyen de libérer un peu d'espacé
autour de roy peut-être la casa fuite
oui mais il ya aussi la case la case des
buts c'est vrai que ça libère aussi des
cases au roi donc dans cette position
fous ces trois le four revient sur la
case c3 alors à noter que cet échec est
ennuyeux puisque si le roi blanc bouge
on voit pas trop où il va exactement où
et puisque en f1 le pion prendrait en g2
sur échec ce serait une catastrophe
ça ça va pas il ya toujours projet de
l'échec subi depuis on prend agenda et
l'option est soutenu par la tour est en
d1 il y aura une fourchette en f2 donc
tout est plus ou moins forcé une
fourchette dite royale puisque sa hâte
avec la dame
le roi et la tour ça tu as toutes les
pièces les plus chers exactement d'en
capter fou b4 caf ou c3 il faut couvrir
les chèques puisqu'on ne peut pas bouger
vous couvrir l'achat qui est vite et
éviter peut-être cavaliers prend
cavalier prendre 5 qui pourrait
intervenir donc fou fou c3 après tout
ces trois donc fou prend fou fou prend
fou peut-être une explication toujours
qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit encore ses
pions blancs ans et 6 ans ou encore
cette triple menace
on a toutes les pièces donc pour
l'instant c'est les noirs
enfin les noirs dans une pièce de plus
mais s'il commence à jouer des petits
coups ses terres des cookies et de
menaces rien qui ne font rien et bien
c'est le banc qui ont gagné ah oui
puisqu'ils ont toutes leurs pièces
surprise au foot rend fou b prend b
prend fou voilà dans des profs ou c'est
intéressant de regarder peut-être
cavaliers prompt qui cavale et profonde
dans cette position qui est évidemment
une possibilité il faut le mentionner
donc cavalier prend fou qui est une
possibilité mais qui qui est beaucoup
moins fort probablement donc à cause de
cavaliers de pions proches et deux
peut-être dans cette position peut-être
peut-être qu'un projet de suivi de
projet de don qui attaquent encore la
tourache donc sur ton projet de la seule
réponse toute façon au diable ces tour
g1 régulièrement et peut être dans cette
position qu'il n'a pas voulu laisser le
cavalier revenir sur la 4c 5 c'est
possible puisqu'on c'est simple cali
fait un excellent travail mais la dame
blanche il défend 17 et il défend b sat
donc ça c'est une possibilité nous
sommes proches 4 comme dans la partie
aussi ou d'un point d'ancrage 4,10 en
cavalière e4 et attaque le pion à f2 ça
c'est possible également jean-luc donc
france et 3b prend ses 3 a priori on va
dire que ça change pas forcément grand
chose car c'est à peu près la même chose
donc qu'il ya des ventes forcées qui
arrive puis en proche des 200 projets de
depuis le temps qu'on l'attendait il
était temps que ce coût à rien puisque
c'était dans le vent on comprenait pas
pourquoi les noirs le jouais pas
maintenant c'est fait tours j'ai un tour
gab2 mais deux donc un coup purement
tactique pour éloigner ce cavalier 2 à 4
c'est une sorte de diversion
c'est à dire qu'on provoque les blancs à
jouer qu'avec champions b2 il ne joue
pas ouais ils préfèrent utiliser ce
cavalier pour l'attack pour l'offensive
et donc il joue autour des 1 la tour est
en attaque et tour des acquis qui
attaque une fois une fois de plus le
cavalier en 17
la ligue est vraiment un superbe combat
là il ya c'est une partie grand
spectacle pour l'instant d'envoyer
quatre pièces blanches contre un
cavalier en 17
vous voyez
d'options noir chez zoé v2 on sait pas
ce qu'ils font là on sait pas ce qu'ils
font là est bien avancée ils sont tous
seuls
exactement donc c'est une position assez
magique
les noirs ont joué dame prend h4 donc le
coup qu'on avait prévu tout à l'heure
donc la dame qui défend le cavaliere au
katla les noirs doivent perdre une pièce
c'est fort c'est donc quitte à perdre
une pièce autant bien placé c'est les
ses propres pièces donc dame proche cat
attaque le pion f2 alors défend le
cavalier leucate défend cavaliers ou
quatre attaques f2 menace donc d'amour
avec deux échecs et mat et en même temps
donc
mais en même temps c'est déjà pas mal en
même temps c'est déjà pas mal mais
libère la case des huit la case des 8
pourrait être utile pour une dernière
pièce c'est à dire la torah 8 qui pourra
éventuellement venir sur cette colonne
un peu plus tard ce coût d'un proche 4
est vraiment le créateur et florence et
le coup parfait c'est le coup parfait
donc dame prend 17 n'apprend 17 on peut
prendre aussi avec le pion on peut
prendre aussi avec le pion probablement
dans cette dans ce cas de figure de
l'ailé noire pourrait jouer roi roi des
oui c'est ça c'est à dire qu'en fait si
on prend avec l'option leroy bloc le
pion une fois pour toute c'est ça le roi
se met devant le pion et trouve en fait
une protection superbe puisqu'on voit
que la dame et la tour et ne peuvent pas
prendre leurs propres pions donc sont
complètement devenue inefficace et
maintenant donc après roi des huit se
serait auto blanc de trouver une parade
adam point f2 échec et mat la
catastrophe tout simplement on ne sait
plus comment défendre toutes les pièces
blanches on voit qu'elles sont mal
placés il ya plus aucune justification
leur honneur est en sécurité et c'est
les noirs qui vont prendre d'initiative
ce n'est pas tolérable surtout que bon
d'un prof de est une menace mais il ya
aussi dame h 4 h 2 qui est une menace
simple et direct la dame donc monnaies
menacent aussi de de prendre la tour
puisque la tourangelle n'a pas beaucoup
de cases donc beaucoup de menaces dans
cette position dame prend 17 roi et
fuite le seul coup dame revient sur des
cats pour défendre le pion f2 pour
éviter l'échec et mat et alors là ça
commence donc un premier sacrifice de
déviation je pense que les noirs ont
peut-être d'autres possibilités mais la
suite qu'a choisi qu'a choisi drief est
une suite de coups forcer une suite de
coups forcé mais extrêmement
spectaculaire donc là à partir de là est
ce qu'on peut dire que les noirs sont
gagnants de manière forcée à partir de
là et peut-être même à partir de
beaucoup plus tôt c'est ça qui est un
quad dans cette partie c'est qu'ils les
coûts sont extrêmement compliquées
probablement une partie qui a été vu et
revu sur un ordinateur probablement mais
à partir de cette position tout est plus
ou moins forcé donc les noirs font d1
dames un sacrifice de déviation puisque
les blancs exerce une pression très
désagréable sur la colonne des donc la
tour doit doit prendre la dame aurait
sinon on a une dame de monts donc voilà
en réalité les blancs et les noirs ne
sacrifie qu'un pion oui tout à fait mais
d'un point de vue esthétique c'est une
dame
c'est ça qui est amusant dans cette
partie tour des huit tours de 8 donc
maintenant qu'on a dévié la batterie
d'un plus tour qui était là donc qui
aurait permis aux blancs de prendre
cette tour des mythes avec échec
et bien pas de problème on peut jouer
tour débute alors voilà donc on vient
d'un petit pont arrière tour des huit et
donc les blancs rendent la pareille au
noir tu m'as donné une dame je t'en
donne une donc pions premier set le pion
prend le cavalier est là la tour
évidemment prend la dame
que se passe-t-il mais non je ne vais
pas donner une dame car j'en fais une
des huit dames
mais voilà donc deux promotions dans
cette partie c'est pas mal la tour
revient sur d8 alors à l'échec
on va revoir on va revoir tout ça parce
que là on a été un petit peu vite
voilà donc bien dame ça c'est le premier
coup dans cette position les noirs
fondane promotion voilà sacrifices donc
ce pion qui vient donc qui est venue de
b4 qui a fait venue en b3 pour faire
divers
pour faire diversion ce puits ont
finalement a fait son chemin et il
arrive jusqu'à la base jusqu'à la case
de promotion en fait ce qu on a fait
diversion jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout
exactement il aura fait diversion juste
que jusqu'à la promotion tour des huit
attaques la dame et maintenant c'est au
noir de faire diversion avec leurs pions
pions province est enfin c'est plutôt la
dame qui fait la diversion pour le pion
pour le trio qui redevient dame donc là
sacrifices les noirs n'ont pas d'autre
choix que de prendre la dame en d4 sinon
c'est fiasco total et une pièce de moins
pour les noirs en attendant jean-luc
qu'il faut et le matériel est payé et
très importants tours pendables donc là
si on reprend la tour c est dire si on
se dit d'une façon malin je vais garder
mon plongent près d'am au coup d'après
on attend je prends la tour maya matin
il ya le problème d'un point m m'attend
de coûts et d'un même problème de suite
dam des deux échecs et mat baby dame
échec
donc là on se prémunit contre le match
en faisant un échec intermédiaire tout
ça c'est très logique tour des huit
défense dame prend à cette dame prend à
cette force est alors l'homme procède ce
n'est pas pour gagner le pion à 7
évidemment mais surtout pour défendre le
mat
voilà sa part ça évite donc dame prend
dame prend un f2 échec et mat est dans
cette position
si on fait un petit bilan donc point
pour l'instant les les blancs ont une
pièce de plus oui mais malheureusement
la menace que l'on avait annoncé tout à
l'heure en début d'émission arrive c'est
à dire qu'on avait dit qu'ils avaient
dame prend f2 qui était une menace mais
il y aussi damage de damages rue qui est
une menace puisque on attaque la tour g1
la tour n'a pas de case la seule manière
de défendre cette tour c'est de monter
le roi en a eu deux alors il ya une
autre manière aussi jolie que c'est de
bouger le pion f1 où il se serait de
bouger le pion f mais dans ce cas là il
y aurait où il y aurait un math en
quelques coins matt rapide donc on va le
montrer il présente sur le coup et f3 il
y aurait donc dame
j'ai trois échecs dames chez trois
chèques d'alger 3 échecs roi de force et
3e de tours d2 échec tour des deux
échecs il y aurait matou perte de la
dame de la dame rose 3 et force est
d'environ 3 et dames f2 échec suivi
suivi de dame prend dame par exemple
s'il n'y a pas mieux mais
l'appareil il ya peut-être mieux mais
ailleurs la machine annonce maintenant
cette danse matters est coup c'est pas
vraiment une surprise oui c'est pas trop
de surprises mais enfin bon on va on va
juste te dire que les noirs sont
gagnants dans cette classe dans cette
direction effectivement on revient donc
un petit peu en arrière donc là d'un
match 2 3 2 renault si on bouge le pion
à fond reste ferme à thé par l'ars et le
coup logique donc on refait le bilan
toujours une pièce de moins pour pour
les blancs mais les noirs ont toujours
l'initiative
ils l'ont conservée depuis une vingtaine
de coups donc les noirs qui ont
initiatives font échec en d2 le roi doit
s'éloigner donc de de son camp il doit
monter sur la case de 3 et là encore
encore encore magnifique tour dans cette
position tour j'ai trois échecs les
noirs qui ont une pièce devient sacrifie
une tour une tour mais c'en est trop si
on prend la tour c'est matt au coup
suivant donc sur pions projet trois
dames pranger trois échecs et mat en
quelques coups une approche droit prend
1,4 suivi de f5
échec et mat un match comme on dit
jean-luc économique afin que chaque
pièce ne sert qu'à une seule chose à
matin à matteo effectivement la dame qui
contrôlent ces cases là
la tour qui contrôlent ces cases là et
les pions qui contrôle en diagonale note
assez économique
voilà donc un très joli match le cap à
tour g3 alors on va on va revoir comme
parce que jean-luc là je trouve que on
va toujours un petit peu trop vite dans
ces moments forts c'est au noir de jouer
le roi blanc est au centre il est à
l'agonie il faut quand même le dire
ils menacent de prendre le câble du 4
mai bon ce qu'il faut voir c'est que les
blancs peuvent éventuellement revenir
avec un petit coup comme dame habite
échec par exemple s'ils savent jouer
suite d'un prêt en cavalier ramenant la
dame en défense et gagnant du matériel
donc les noirs doivent prouver quelque
chose dans cette position où les noirs
ne peuvent pas temporiser dans cette
position ils doivent
ils doivent exécuter le faut l'exécuter
il faut exécuter ce roi qui en a eu
trois c'est leur chance le roi est monté
il faut il faut l'agressé immédiatement
donc tout rejet 3 c'est le coup le plus
efficace à noter que les autres coups il
ya d'autres coûts qui sont intéressants
aussi comme tourcoing f2 qui doit gagner
mettons g3 c'est l'exécution c'est
vraiment le peloton d'exécution
voilà touché 300 g iii donc la plus
belle suite cf range étroit dans cette
position bon on va pas lui en vouloir à
sokolov puisqu'il a quand même passé une
sale journée parce que ce cette partie
quand même c'est une c'est une punition
qui n'est pas vraiment justifiée puisque
bon c'est quand même beaucoup de
préparation mais c'est quand même du
beau spectacle
et là il a terminé la partie donc pas
roi prend 1,4 et tours j'ai catéchètes
c'est fini les noirs vont matteo coup
suivant sur n'importe quel coût de roy
la dame bien sûr la case f4 et ses
échecs et mat que l'euro revienne en a
eu trois ou en f3 même punition
la dame qui remontera sur la case f4
c'est à dire cette case là et ça sera
matt donc là c'est terminé
donc voilà on revoit un petit peu la
combinaison ralenti on peut revoir au
ralenti mais puisque ça commence il ya
un bout de temps de cela avec dans cette
position donc là nous sommes revenus au
24e coup de la partie les blancs ont
joué donc d'amd 4 et c'est au noir de
jouer voilà donc c'est comme difficile
difficilement prévisible c'est pas
évident est-ce qu'il avait tout calculé
pas sûr mais en tout cas ça marche
je pense qu'il avait tout calculé il y
avait tout calculé alors donc d1 dames
diversion dont la première diversion
tout reprend dame fort ses forces et on
a une dame de moi il faut la récupérer
tour des beats tour des huit attaques la
dame puis on prend des êtres contre
contredit version contredit version
condamne la dame des blancs les noirs
prennent tout reprend des quatre des
huit dames échec donc deux promotions
quasi consécutive c'est assez rare tour
des huit échecs dames propension à cette
défend le matin à f2 l'important
maintenant donc on a une piste de moi
mais on a la menace l'attaquent de la
tourangelle par dame h 2 donc on voit
que comparé à la position précédente où
quand on a commencé pour jouer bien dame
est bien dans cette position on a réussi
à mettre notre temps débute en jeu et
c'est ça qui change tout puisque avant
si les blancs qui avaient la colonne des
dons qu'on peut faire l'analogie entre
les deux positions jean-luc
pour bien expliquer la force donc la
premier cas c'est comme ça exactement on
voit un peu joué d'un match de l'eiblen
les blancs donc sont très très puissant
sur le sur la colonne des et après ce
coup après la séquence
après ben d'armes
ils vont perdre la colonne la commande
est tout à fait après la séquence on se
retrouve dans la même position enfin la
même situation toujours très noir mais
comme ça donc et noir ont donné du
matériel mais ils ont pris la colonne
des évidemment il faut préciser c'est
que cette colonne des est un espace
vital nécessaire pour le roi blanc
effectivement c'est ce qui permet donc
de faire des matchs 2 c'est ce qui va
lui manquer donc le roi doit monter sur
7 sur la colonne eux c'est le seul
couloir qui lui reste dans cette
position et ce couloir va rétrécir de
manière un petit peu suffocante
c'est puisque c'est à dire eric leroy
après tour des deux doit monter en trois
tours j'ai 3 il doit monter en 4 s'est
imposé leur imposer le couloir de la
mort dont j'ai quatre essais terminés il
se fait mater c'est le couloir de la
mort donc superbe victoire de relief
contre sokolov
jean luc est ce qu'on peut dire que
c'était préparation préparation on peut
dire qu'il ya une grosse part de
préparation mais il ya aussi une part
d'improvisation
je pense pas que drief a calculé cette
partie jusqu'au bout il n'a pas pris
enfin je pense qu'il a calculé beaucoup
de choses sur l'échiquier mais qui n'a
pas prévu tout ce qui s'est passé avant
il ya une grande part d'intuition et et
je conseille donc je conseille aux
téléspectateurs de revoir cette partie
attentivement effectivement elle est
extrêmement compliquée cette partie
jean-luc voilà donc vous pouvez
évidemment la revoir elle est à côté
dans le pg n sur la droite de votre
écran
on va maintenant passer à la rubrique
jean-luc chavanon c'est à dire la
rubrique chasse people de la semaine
chasse people la rubrique de jean-luc
chavanon avec donc peu d'activité en ce
moment mais il y avait une petite un
petit divertissement jeu reprend
jean-luc que tu as raté
oui j'aimerais donc j'ai rater mad max
mais tu vas nous en dire un petit peu
plus sur mad max max max était donc une
troupe de comédiens qui se produisaient
à paris improvisations autour du jeu
d'échec on a vu là bas la présence d'un
antoine blanc shapira le manager de
kasparov qui est venu soutenir cette
troupe de comédiens dont il y avait pas
mal d'animations sympathique donc parmi
les thèmes d'impro proposées on a vu les
fous des l'épeule la passion le côté
passion on a vu pas mal de choses très
très intéressante
voilà donc au programme aujourd'hui
pourchasse people nous allons parler
donc de arnaud hauchard jean luc est ce
que tu peux déjà commenté l'une est
peut-être voilà donc mes lunettes sont
les lunettes la copie conforme des
minettes d'igor donc igor nataf qui va
bientôt jouer donc à paris ou ailleurs
nataf grands maîtres français de 1965
sera jaune très grand espoir très
intrigante espoirs parisiens qui sera
attendue donc très attendu au sénat et
qui va avec arnaud hauchard qui vont
après le sénat qui vont filer à cuba
qu'il faut jouer un très grand tournoi à
cuba donc notre correspondant parisien
john caby les a suivis hier soir donc il
a passé la soirée avec eux ils ont été
open
hier soir donc dans une discothèque très
branché de paris ce pays c'est très
moche et le peuple voilà donc et on
rappelle donc que ces joueurs
retourneront probablement le dans un
mois dans cette boîte puisqu'il gagne
soirée mousse soirée mousse au pulp dans
un mois donc voilà igor nataf et arnaud
chars qui sont les fêtards de
l'échiquier je pense qu'on peut on peut
le dire sur twitter nataf qui est donc
très habitué aux sorties en boîte alors
jean-luc qu'est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
cette semaine
voilà donc cette semaine nous allons
nous allons principalement de parler de
cinéma
nous allons parler de cinéma puisque
c'est la grande sortie de la défense
nous
donc la défense origines de marlene
goris donc énorme panneau nabokov c'est
le livre non c'est le film cette fois
donc oui évidemment tu y es ce film qui
est tiré du roman du célèbre écrivain
vladimir nabokov
voilà donc je crois que la distribution
est magnifique pour ce film puisque
marling auris a choisi comme acteurs
principaux
john turturro donc un acteur
l'acteur fétiche des frères coen et de
spike lee et de spike lee donc on
rappelle un petit peu la carrière de
john turturro de jeunes toreros qui est
qui a tourné donc dans votre big
lebowski des frères coen oui on se
rappelle de ressources
et oui c'était jesús c'était jesús queen
tana donc dans le big lebowski john
tortures qu'y jouer au bowling alors que
les joueurs d'échecs joue au billard et
il a tourné aussi dans summer of sam de
spike lee un grand classique
oui tout à fait on va peut-être parler
un peu des échecs quand même jean-luc on
va parler un petit peu des échecs mais
bon on va quand même parler de cinéma
dont combat on va bien expliqué ce film
donc et billy watson qui est donc qui
est l'actrice de ce film
gauthier germain qui est cher c'est très
très jolie voilà donc on va donc
raconter un petit peu un petit peu ce
qui s'est passé donc l'histoire du film
donc ça se passe dans les années 30
alors déjà juste petite précision c'est
tiré du roman de nabokov ça on l'a déjà
dit mais nabokov était un joueur
d'échecs et notamment un compositeur de
problèmes d'échec
oui ça se met ses limites et donc en
fait le gars savait de quoi il parlait
exactement donc nabokov qui qui explique
bien puisqu'on n'a qu'un vu beaucoup de
films autour du jeu d'échecs qui a été
fait par des gens qui ne connaissaient
pas ou très peu le milieu des échecs et
donc ça a donné quand même des certaines
raté les winners là c'est peut-être pas
forcément câble exactement donc on ça
fait plaisir mais bon on a beau coffret
d'origine russe donc ça explique
pourquoi il chausse échec dans ses
années folles voilà donc ça se passe
dans les années trente et un matches est
organisée donc entre entre entre john
turturro donc qui joue le rôle de loup
jean d'alexander ivanovic eugene et qui
opposait donc à un joueur italien donc à
un grand champion italien ils vont jouer
un tournoi dans un château de comme donc
en italie c'est un cadre magnifique et
donc à l'issue de ce match
le titre de champion du monde sera
décerné donc match pour le titre de
champion du monde alors que je crois le
jean a un caractère tout à fait
particulier
oui lojie d'un caractère extrêmement
particulier puisque il a eu une enfance
perturbée si on peut le dire donc c'est
une description psychologique
intéressante donc d'un champion d'échecs
description qu'on a l'habitude de voir
au cinéma mais c'est pas mal c'est très
très bien et il est replié sur lui-même
au cinéma on a souvent tendance à mettre
en avant le côté un peu fou des joueurs
d'échecs un petit peu je dirais
schizophrène le côté spectacle on va
dire dr c'est un joueur c'est un joueur
qui est très rentrée sur lui-même
alors que c'est complètement faux il
faut il ya très très peu de joueurs
comme ça et ça n'arrive
oui c'est un cas exceptionnel mais on
utilise cette image donc pour pour le
cinéma
quelques joueurs quand même je dois
avouer qu on a vu quand même l'année
dernière l'interview de deux grilles de
chou qui est on doit vous de certains
joueurs de devenir divan de choc dit
vendredi 20h au pouvoir dans diagonale
les émissions consacrées au tournoi 2
jean-luc c'est toi qui avait fait le
reportage
c'était à monte carlo c'est ça oui donc
oui c'était à monaco c'était ma mélodie
amber de l'année dernière donc dans les
archives de diagonale voilà donc
on va revenir un petit peu au film est
donc ce john torture tombe amoureux
d'emily watson qui donc l'héroïne de
breaking the waves donc très connu et
tombe amoureux de d'emily watson dans le
film et il se heurte un petit peu donc à
la famille d'abord dans un premier temps
à la merde
d'emily watson donc qu' on va pas
raconter tout le film quand même on va
pas raconter tout le film bon c'est une
histoire d'amour c'est un
c'est un beau roman et est donc une
belle histoire et oui exactement et on
on voit un petit peu donc le rôle qu'a
le jeu d'échecs donc danser
dans ses passions fortes valeurs de
question qu'on a envie de poser un déjà
est ce que le film va plus le film a plu
énormément aller le voir
d'accord et deuxième question est-ce que
c'est réaliste
est-ce que c'est réaliste ce n'est pas
réaliste sais tu que c'est une belle
histoire c'est une belle histoire
d'amour et mais c'est de la fiction un
pur ont peut-être parler de jean becker
quand même qu'il est un joueur d'échecs
averti puisqu'on doit régulièrement au
jardin du luxembourg ou alors au cercle
dans des cercles d'échec
jean becker qui est donc je crois avait
acheté les droits de d'interprétation du
livre de nabokov
il y a déjà presque vingt ans et qui
finalement les a redonné à des
américains oui donc c'est c'était sa
volonté dont qui au début donc il
voulait il voulait tourner le film
il avait d'ailleurs pensé par un joueur
français pour jouer le rôle du jeune du
jeune loup jean il avait pensé etienne
bacrot oui mais bon sang projet ne s'est
pas réalisé
et donc finalement il il a dû il a dû
finalement se contenter de le revendre
d'un coup les américains se seraient ce
serait bien donc que tu invites jean
becker pour une émission
ce serait une idée très bien tout à fait
nous allons il pensait d'autant plus que
le film est à l'affiché en ce moment la
défense lot jean avec john turturro et
emily watson toujours au cinéma donc on
a pu gagner des places sur internet on
peut également aller voir c'est un très
bon film dont jean-luc moi je n'ai pas
encore vu puisque j'ai en ce moment je
suis débordée par l'actualité du reste
du monde qui est très très chargé
notamment jean-luc le grand prix du
sénat qu'il arrivait la semaine
prochaine on y reviendra en fin
d'émission
en attendant victor kornoi
donc je pense qu'on a fini à brutus
people à moins qu'il ya encore un petit
truc que j'ai oublié mais je ne crois
pas non c'est parfait c'est parfait donc
aller voir le film le film sort atari en
ce moment et
et dans toute la france rien à dire sur
laurent frayssinet laurent frayssinet
non on va se contenter de dire laurent
fasciné on va se contenter donc voilà
laurent frayssinet ne vois là il n'a
rien fait d'exceptionnel cette semaine
on le retrouvera en nationale 1 c'est
d'ailleurs là dessus que nous allons
enchaîner la nationale 1 championnat de
france par équipe qui aura lieu donc ce
week end à montpellier avec clichy
monaco duel au sommet jean luc tu joues
dans l'équipe de cannes qui est donc en
ce moment troisième quel est le moral
des troupes à cannes 1 le mollah le
moral est au beau fixe on joue pour le
titre janvier en france exactement nous
voulons être champion de france
ça va être difficile puisque puisque
clichy est une très très forte équipe
mais nous avons également une très bonne
équipe je rappelle qu'à clichy
joël lautier joue et à cannes c'est
etienne bacrot et vladislav quatre chefs
qui sont donc les meneurs de l'est
buteur de l'équipe
les buteurs de l'équipe à noter que ces
deux très belles équipes clichy qui
affiche une moyenne et l'eau à plus de
2500 30 points ce qui est tout à fait
considérable sur neuf et chic et il ya
un échiquier féminin on le rappelle donc
loin sans clichy gros favoris ce week
end donc match au sommet cannes clichy
monaco contre clichy tout le monde va
essayer de battre clichy mais pour
l'instant ils ont un point d'avancé
l'équipe de jean-claude - donc les
hommes de jean-claude partent évidemment
favoris dans cette phase finale de
nationale or ce week end également au
programme jean luc un semi rapide c'est
un week-end anniversaire
et oui donc c'est l'anniversaire de
victor cortona et enfin c'était il ya un
mois et il a 70 ans et pour ses 70 ans
donc
on organise un tournoi donc en suisse
c'est la firme chasse base qui organise
ou en tout cas qui va retransmettre ce
tournoi superbe tournoi semi rapide
ensuite avec garry kasparov et vladimir
car ni avec les deux cas donc les deux
cas qui se retrouvent à nouveau depuis
depuis le vif depuis linares n'avait pas
encore joué donc et qui n'ont à linares
y avait pas chronique
en revanche at il été agrandi depuis je
vis choisit donc ils vont se retrouver à
nouveau en partie rapide et ça sera une
première confrontation avant le tournoi
qui aura lieu au kazakhstan dans
quelques mois le fameux tournant du
kazakhstan donc voilà sont invités à ce
tournoi
garry kasparov l'admirent crown et peter
steele erna giorgio une piquette boris
spassky notre champion français zigert
c'est un vieux joueur de la génération
de kornoi yannick pelletier werner pub
florian jenny richard forster c'est 3,4
suisse lit donc il ya yannick pelletier
qui est évidemment le leader de l'équipe
suisse werner lui qui a été champion du
monde juniors il ya très très longtemps
il ya très très longtemps donc on
souhaite à victor corchia est évidemment
un très bon anniversaire
rappelons que c'est quand même le
poulidor des échecs mais un excellent
joueur un joueur fantastique qui a
toujours terminé 2e qui n'a pas réussi à
battre
anatoly karpov dans ses grandes années
voilà donc bonne anniversaire victor et
il y aura donc dans ce tournoi boris
spassky qui viendra la semaine prochaine
dans diagonale le grand boris spassky
champion du monde de 69 à 72 pour
jean-luc le grand prix du sénat oui
c'est canal web c'est un plaisir
d'inviter donc boris on
en france puisque c'est quand même le
champion du monde français
il y avait les filles n'ont fini il y
avait les quines mais bon boris est
toujours là parmi nous et c'est un
plaisir l'année dernière il avait fait
des parties magnifique au sénat je me
souviens de ce sacrifice qui l'avait
fait contre arnaud hauchard s'était il a
fait un match de toute beauté contre
arnaud et là on espère qu'au sénat elle
avait fini par craquer en finale l'année
dernière contre shirov donc on rappelle
la formule du sénat jean luc c'est donc
quatre joueurs de donc un tirage au sort
qui aura lieu la semaine prochaine dans
diagonale à 21h comme d'habitude
vendredi prochain tirage au sort donc il
ya boris spassky joël lautier laurent
frayssinet christian bauer deux contre
deux et ensuite les vainqueurs se
rencontrent en finale
et oui donc l année dernière ils
s'étaient qualifiés pour la finale mais
la finale il l'avait perdue contre
alexei shirov c'était prévisible n'est
pas facile avec sa fiancée
c'est exactement mais cette année ça va
être très très intéressant cette année
donc tournoi assez chaud donc alors tu
commenceras pour internet jean-luc
puisque ça sera des directs marathon
c'est le week-end du 5 et 6 mai week-end
marathon donc six heures de direct par
jour avec tous les matches en
intégralité des reportages sur le sénat
en tout cas la semaine prochaine y en
aura aussi dans la la conférence de
presse vous êtes invités à venir
participer à l'émission donc dans le
public à canal web à paris 20ème troyon
donc pour cela vous envoyez un mail à
diagonale canal vote point net et vous
pourrez venir personnellement poser des
questions aux champions au cours de
l'émission
ça c'est pour la semaine prochaine sinon
il ya le grand prix du sénat il ya
encore quelques places qui sont
disponibles toujours un mail à diagonale
pour canal web point net le mail donc
décanale @ canal point net
il y encore quelques places on vous les
envoient par la poste ou fait une
confirmation par mail pour vous mettre
sur la liste il ya encore des
possibilités donc jean luc ça va être un
très beau tournoi et la semaine
prochaine une conférence de presse où
pourra poser les questions qu'on veut
aux champions parce qu'il ya des
questions qui intriguent déjà oui je
voudrais savoir donc je veux savoir les
motivations de laurent frayssinet donc
laurent frayssinet qui les motive et qui
est très motivés donc en partie rapide
c'est un grand spécialiste donc
il s'est bien comporté à enghien donc
j'aimerais bien savoir si cette fois il
a l'intention de faire mieux que joël
lautier qui est probablement quand même
le favori c'est le favori au classement
mais il faut savoir quand même que
christian bauer et laurent frayssinet
donc sont des spécialistes des parties
rapides et boris est également très très
dangereux bassir que boris est quand
même capable sur sur un instant de
battre n'importe qui puisqu'il l'a déjà
fait il a battu tout le monde
à une certaine époque dont boris
toujours là pour faire la surprise ou en
tout cas pour confirmer éventuelles et
voilà et puis aussi leur demander leurs
impressions sur le film leurs
impressions sur le climat là on verra ça
jean-luc puisque ce film m'a beaucoup
intéressé on verra ça la semaine
prochaine 21h conférence de presse
ouverte au public qui voulait des places
pour participer au grand prix du sénat
pour venir dans le public dans la salle
c'est à paris au jardin du luxembourg
donc ça c'est possible
toujours un mail diagonale @ canal
planète on vous remercie d'avoir suivi
cette édition jean luc merci merci loi
et on donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour la conférence de presse